You are listening to radio lab radio from w n y.
S t e n n p. R.
One when you die, we can all agree on this.
Something changes.
You get the feeling that's something that was there, isn't there or leaves.
But what leave one, two, three. Can you hear me? We talked to a biologist,
a at Princeton University, Lee silver,
who told us a story about a guy back in 1907 who did a very interesting
experiment. His name was Dunkin McDougal. I Dunno,
I don't remember exactly who he was, was he was, he was a doctor, a doctor,
a physician. And what's his story?
He wanted to prove that the soul exited the body after.
Yeah.
He thought the sole had a certain amount of weight, that it was a substance.
And so what he did was he had these people who were dying from tuberculosis and
he studied, they were lying on beds on this gigantic scale.
He literally put people almost dying onto a way unto a scale. Yes.
So imagine how a patient on one side of the scale and on the other side are
weights and they're there in perfect balance.
And then at the moment of death, right at the last breath,
he tried to determine whether or not the scale changed.
So did they lose weight when they died? That was the question. Right?
And he claimed that on average they lost 21 grams the instant they died.
Oh,
did it as he described the moment that suddenly the scales shift one way or the
other. Yeah, the moment,
I mean death was easy in those days because you stopped breathing.
You were dead. I mean there were, there weren't,
they weren't hooked into brain scans. Right. So it's the, the last breath.
Last Fan. Yes. Um, and the New York Times headline was so has wait,
physician thinks, right. Great headline. Right?
And this is the beginning of the 20th century.
We're not talking about medieval times to remember that.
What did he conclude from this soul has weight. Okay.
I seen a soul.
It was there when he was alive and it flew off and it weighs 21 grams. Yes. Now,
there was one person whose weight didn't change immediately.
It changed a minute later.
And so his hypothesis was that this was a very kind of dumb guy and the soul
was, they didn't realize it was free. And so it took a minute after the death,
before the salt realized it was freeing. It flew out of but the bottom,
so a true idiot, we'd be hanging out like your for five
now. This was very serious. Of course. Yeah.
How would you explain what he saw or thought?
He saw the 21 grams? I'm still stuck on that. I mean, 21 grams.
It's statistically insignificant.
I mean,
three quarters of an ounce compared to the weight of a body is a minuscule
amount. Particularly he says, Lee,
when you consider how crude the scales were at the time,
almost anything could have swayed them. I'll breeze the pressure.
Anything really, uh, today, hey, we'd be laughed out of the academy.
You ever seen someone die or ever seen a dead person? I've seen dead people.
I mean, I've seen dead bodies. [inaudible] I've [inaudible] do you, I mean I,
I just want my mom just before she died, just after she died. Yes.
And I thought to myself, um,
there's a real difference here. It's,
it's beyond power or it's a,
it's a very noticeable deep absence of something.
And it does make you think that something,
I'll use the word carefully. Vital has gone away suddenly.
[inaudible] we have to be very careful about the words.
I mean something has gone away,
the brain has ceased to function and therefore I would say there is no person.
It's still the unanswered question is what really happens in that moment when a
person is suddenly
gone
to the other side, the other side,
those of us with the benefit of being alive cannot help but ask this question.
It's like a curse. We want to know.
But obviously it's not something you can though.
Yeah.
Cause this will just always be one of those domains where the tools of science
just can't be used. Alas. But then there are those folks like neuroscientist,
David Eagleman who say screw it. We're going to ask.
We're going to wonder cause that's just what we do.
When you walk to the end of the pier of science,
you look out and you've got everything beyond that.
You've got the whole ocean of what we don't know. Cast the end of the pier.
What a scientist does is sort of leap out onto different islands and just try
things out. I'm Jad Abumrad and I am Robert [inaudible]. Today on radio lab,
we're going to do what David Eagleman suggest. We're just going to hop around.
This is unusual for us,
but with that we're going to look at different aspects of yeah,
and the other side in no particular order, but here's what we can tell you.
We're going to make 11 stops, 11 meditations,
shall we call them on various questions relating to death and die and what
happens after
won't be depressing. No, you just heard the first one. Soul has weight,
physician thinks. Here's our second [inaudible] comes to us from a,
the guy you just heard David Eagleman who is a neuroscientist but wrote a book
called some. Yeah. Which is very not neurosciencey at all. Truth is,
I haven't talked about this book with any of my science colleagues. Why not?
I have reasons why, but I'm not sure I want to say them on the radio.
In any case,
the book consists of 40 different versions of the afterlife and here's one,
it's called metamorphosis written by David Eagleman and read by Jeffrey Tambor,
the Ecuador, right? There are three depths.
Now the first is when the body ceases to function of course,
and the second is when the body is consigned or you know,
put in the grave.
The third is that moment sometime in the future when your name is spoken or the
last time
[inaudible]. So
you wait in this lobby until the third death.
There are long tables with coffee and tea cookies.
You can help yourself in there.
There are people here from all around the world and with a little effort you can
strike up some awesome convivial small talk.
Just be aware that your conversation could be interrupted at any moment by a
while. We call them
the colors,
and what they do is they broadcast your new friend's name
to indicate that there will never again be another remembrance of him by anyone
on the earth.
[inaudible]
your friend's slumps saddened. Even though the callers, they tell them kindly,
look, you're, you're, you're off to a better place. The thing is,
no one knows where that better place is or what it offers because no one exiting
through that door has returned to tell us
[inaudible]
and tragically, many people leave just as their loved ones arrive.
Since the loved ones,
we're the only ones doing the remembering and we all have our heads at that
typical timing. Now,
not everyone is sad with her callers.
Shout out their next list of names on the contrary. Some people beg,
they plead. These are generally the guys who've been here a long time.
[inaudible] too long. [inaudible]
I take that farmer over there who drowned in a small river 200 years ago.
I get this,
his farm is the side of a small college now and the tour guides each week tell
his story. So he, he's, he's stuck.
[inaudible]
he's miserable. The more his story is told,
the more the details drift.
He's utterly alienated from his name and it's no longer identical with him,
but it continues to bind and that cheerless woman across the way is praised as a
saint
even though the roots in her heart, believe me, we're complicated
and
I guess that is the curse of this room
because since we live in the heads of those who remember us,
we lose control of our lives and become who they are.
Why not us
to be?
What gave you the idea for that story? This is actually, um, I should say, um,
came out of my work as a neuroscientist because what happens in the brain is you
make models of other people when you think, well,
what would my friends such and such say, or what would my wife say?
You're actually running a little simulation of that person in your head.
Well,
what happens when somebody dies is then they exist only in the scattered heads
around the globe of people who knew them.
They exist in some way as these algorithms that continue to run.
But through time you, your model of somebody might drift.
[inaudible] [inaudible] are we ready?
Uh, number three, I'm going to change up the question a bit. William, am I dead?
[inaudible]
how do you decide if somebody is alive or dead?
If you take as your starting point, King Lear Shakespeare,
when Cordelia, his daughter died
[inaudible]
near takes out a mirror.
Let me looking guys puts it right under her nose to see if there is some breadth
there. Is that to have breast
fed just the same thing.
And that is how he decides if she's on.
Yes. And it's really one of the most beautiful scenes in Shakespeare.
That's Gary Greenberg. He wrote a book called the noble lie.
When it's done right, it's impossible not to weep.
She has gone farther at that scene
and the intimacy
of that moment.
But if you fast forward a few hundred years, things change.
Alright, is 1816,
there's a fat lady in a hospital where in France and in walks a guy by the,
what was his name? [inaudible]
Mack lantack. Yeah, he's a doctor. He's a dust fellow. Okay. Yes.
And he is called in to consult with, uh,
a patient who is obese, obese, and ill. He says to this lady, please,
may I see your wrist so that I can feel your pulse.
But this woman had so much flesh on her that the only way he could imagine to do
it was to put his ear on her chest, which would have been in decent
mm.
So came up with an idea he fabricated quite quickly.
A device rolled up paper really and fashion did into a tube,
put one end of the tube on the woman's chest and his year on the other end. Oh,
how very decent of him. So he doesn't have to touch her flesh.
He doesn't have to even really look at her chest.
His head is actually turned away from the patient. And so
what we've got here in 1816 is the world's first stethoscope and a very,
an intimate, budding,
increasingly precise and technological approach to defining death,
which now is all about the heart. Up until then,
a death was heart death. People are dead when their heart stops speeding.
But if you fast forward again, things take another term,
like just imagine thought experiment.
If King Lear had been written not in 1604 but 1968
LBJ administration, gay, Cordelia, [inaudible]
die,
there would be distraught. But instead of doing the mirror thing again,
he would call a doctor who would rush her to the hospital, shock her heart,
resuscitate her, hooked her up to a ventilator and a feeding tube.
And there she would be alive again.
Sort of. I mean technically, yes, she'd be alive cause her heart would be,
but the core Delia that he knew his daughter would be gone.
[inaudible]
and this was the problem in 1968 with all this new technology,
ICU units were filling up with these purgatorial Cordelia's who floated
somewhere in a comatose state between life and death.
You could minister to these people, you could feed them,
you could clear their infections, but you could not restore the consciousness.
What are you going to do with these people? In walks a physician,
a very prominent American physician named Henry Beecher,
and he decided that the time had come to acknowledge the obvious,
which to him was these people weren't just dying, they were dead.
He convened a committee at Harvard and he simply moved the line that divides
life from death back a little bit toward what most people would consider life.
And so you get in that moment, the concept of brain death person is really dead.
We really did not, when they stop breathing, not when their heart stops beating,
but when their brain winks out,
that now is when a person really dies. Exactly.
Totally invented concept, but it stuck.
One way to argue it was that the brain was considered to be sort of the Maestro,
the coordinating Oregon that made all of the rest of the body work and without
it, the center no longer holds and things fall apart.
And nowadays most people go with this brain dead definition of death.
But where it gets weird is it?
There are some holdouts, just a few. For instance,
some sex of Orthodox Judaism will say that if the heart is beating,
the lungs are still filling with Aaron. If the lungs are still filling with air,
still a soul,
the spirit of God is in you and you certainly can't be said to be dead. Well,
I'll give you another example. That's John Troyer,
associate of death and dying practices at the University of bath. For example,
Italy, they use the brain death criteria. The Vatican, however it's own city,
state within the country of Italy does not.
The Vatican goes only by heart death. So technically according to John,
it's possible that if I were brain-dead and Italy and doctor wanted to pull my
plug, but my family didn't,
they could just wheel me down the street into the Vatican and I'd be alive
again.
Yeah,
I mean you'd need a really long extension cord probably cause of course these
are all,
I mean you'd be on machines and devices that require power so you can meet.
It would be a laborious process to say the least. Nonetheless,
the real question here, the deeper one is in when do you die?
Is it brain versus heart? It's when are you gone?
Like when is a father, a son, a daughter
really gone to us and who gets to decide that? And that's there in lies.
The rub dead to family can be very different than dead to an institution that
might be caring for that body.
You know that that scene of lear with the mirror is in the feathers.
It's not a medical diagnosis.
It's a diagnosis about love and loss. Ooh,
stay little
and number four tennis. Anyone,
let me tell you about a woman. She, we see a victim of a,
a road traffic accident. So that's Dr Adrian Owen.
He's a neuroscientist at the University of Cambridge.
And he told me about this patient. He had
a patient who's in her thirties and she came to us after five months in a
vegetative state following a blow to her head.
So for five months she'd been lying in the hospital,
couldn't talk or couldn't move. He could breathe,
but no evidence of any awareness would shine light in her eyes.
She wouldn't have the normal response in the fact that woman was gone.
That's right.
But in spite of the fact that she was giving the world nothing back,
Dr. Owen wondered, would it just be possible that there was somebody in there?
So we tried a new kind of approach with her. Yeah.
Because they had a new and sophisticated tool that previous site is,
I never had any rain scanner. Yeah. This is a stethoscope for the brain.
Dr. Owen stood by her bedside and said, tell you what,
in a few minutes we're going to take you to a machine. You chat with her.
You say, hey,
that's exactly how it's done. Yes, it sounds, um,
a little bit bizarre because of course you don't get any responses back from
these patients. You don't even know whether they can hear you, but we, you know,
we might instructions very clear. Yeah.
And he says, now when we put you in the machine,
there's going to be a click and I'm going to say into your ear, please begin
to imagine playing a vigorous game of tennis.
[inaudible]
we said, imagine that you're standing there at the base line,
Wimbledon carrying out the movements.
Dennis. See, because here's the thing.
We now know enough about brains to know that if you are imagining tennis, yeah.
Well, produce activity in your motor cortex.
Probably similar to the activity that you would see if you could scan somebody
when they were actually playing a game of tennis
and this is true of all healthy people. That's right. Oh, it's the same pattern.
Yeah. It lights up very reliably. Okay,
so he puts this patient into a brain scan and then he rolls her into the machine
and we say, right, play tennis now relax,
play tennis. Not really.
You said this woman's been vacant for five months? Yeah,
I get to see this seems quite literally a shot or a forehand in the dark.
This was his first patient. Really? He does this. He says, play,
stop, play, stop.
She hadn't spoken or showing any sense of awareness or any interior life at all
for months and months and months and months and
on the screen. Here's a tennis game.
[inaudible]
what we saw is exactly what we see in healthy volunteers.
No premotor cortex is turning on and turning off. When we asked her to relax,
turning on,
we also have to do the task,
then it would stop when we asked her to relax. So she's in there,
she's in there. Oh,
were you amazed or were you expect it, what were you,
what happened to you?
Um, well, yeah, I mean it, it was,
it was pretty exciting.
I'm going to have to say the fact that it was the first person we tried it in
with.
It was perhaps the biggest surprise and we've scanned about 20 patients since
then doing the same thing. And we've, we've seen three so far who, uh,
showed clear signs of, uh, of being aware.
See, that's the thing that sort of frightens me about what you've done.
It seems to me you've discovered that there may have been,
and there may be lots of people in this world who are somehow aware but who are
invisible to the rest of us whom we could in effect murder a by mistake.
Yeah. Well that's obviously very, um, loaded question.
Uh, I mean I think we, you know,
we have to face the side that historically we haven't always had the tools that
we have today that can help us to make complex decisions.
But we're very early stages of this and they're awesome.
Some also very technical reasons why one needs to be extremely cautious about
drawing conclusions from this. For example, you know,
we could tell with this patient that she was aware and what we can't do is to
conclude that the rest of them were definitely unaware.
Imagine if you were stone deaf and you appeared to be in a vegetative state.
Now in that situation,
we wouldn't necessarily know that you were stone deaf because you've,
you've had a major brain injury and we can't talk to you and find out.
So we don't know that you're stone deaf.
We put you in the scan and we asked you to imagine playing tennis.
But you can't even hear the instructions. Actually,
that patient wouldn't imagine playing tennis.
They wouldn't activate their premotor cortex.
But it wouldn't be because they weren't aware it would be because they were
deaf.
Oh dear.
So even though we can tell when a patient is aware,
we can't tell when a patient is unaware, and that's very,
very important distinction.
But if you can't really know that someone is unaware
and then you can't actually ever really know if they're gone.
[inaudible]
we've entered into this very difficult space where we have learned enough to
know that we know much less than we thought.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
message one. Hi, this is Gary Greenberg.
Radio lab is funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting and the National Science Foundation.
Message to Ken Baldwin.
Radiolab is produced by W W N Y C and distributed by the National Public Radio
and this message.
Hello, I'm Jad. I boomerang. I remember Krulwich Radiolab.
We're back from our break. Yes we do. During our breaks,
which would you say we do during our breaks, we don't do anything.
We don't exist really. And we're going to continue with our show here today.
How many meditations?
1111 meditations on things relating to death and what happens after,
but we're not up to 11 this is a five. Five.
It's called four seconds down from producers who were in wheeler. Wake up.
Everything's pretty black.
Same as it has been last couple of weeks. This is Ken Baldwin.
The day he's talking about is August 20th, 1985.
Say Goodbye to my wife and I just say, you know, I'll be home late.
Do some overtime at the time he was living couple hours east of San Francisco.
Why? Say I love her and uh,
I know right now that I won't survive the day.
She has no idea how I feel. Everything is,
is dark, everything is, is black.
So I get in my car,
I'm just not a very good person drive to work cause I think maybe, uh,
maybe I can do it one more day closer.
I get to work the more I realize I've, I've,
I've got to disappear to,
to start over and get rid of whatever it is I've got.
It's got to end. I drive right past work and then I'm on the uh,
freeway. Kind of relaxed. Yeah.
Finally a see the bridge and it's, it's huge. It's gigantic.
He parks his car at the bridge, puts money in the meter
and uh,
I start walking and I'm walking on the bridge just like any other tourists.
It's a beautiful day. It's a gorgeous Wednesday.
I see everything around me and it's just gorgeous.
And I find a place, it's, it's an outcropping.
You can see straight down into the water. And I say,
ah, this is time to do it. You really got to do this.
I really believed that everybody would be better off without me,
that everybody would just get on with their lives feeling better about me being
gone than me being here. I put my hands on the,
on the railing count to 10.
Yup. And I vaulted over.
And the last things I, uh,
saw leave the bridge where my hands and that moment
[inaudible]
that very moment I said, oh my God, this is a mistake
and nothing I can do about it. It's a fall,
the fall from the bridge to the water, it takes about four seconds.
And it was almost like a quick flickers of what I was trying to think of my
family, my daughter, three years old,
I'll never see her grow up the things she's going to see that I don't get to see
man, the misery that I caused. This is bad.
I'm sorry guys that I did this to you.
I do want to listen to how it's going to end.
I just blacked out
and I woke up and I was swimming for my life and I was saying, oh my God,
somebody please save me somebody. Somebody saved me.
He hit the water and a ball. He bruised his feet, his backside,
but no serious injuries.
Some workers saw him jump and called the coast guard
and then the next thing I remember I was on the coast guard cutter.
Only 26 people have made it onto that boat out of a thousand or so that have
jumped and nearly all of them say that in the middle of the fall when they're
facing their death, something inside them changed.
Mm.
They didn't want to die.
For Ken.
That change happened the very moment he saw his hands leave the bridge.
I can see that perfectly.
[inaudible]
I can, I can, I can see my hands leave the bridge. I don't know if it was a,
if it was a mechanical switch or a, you know, um,
some kind of switch in the brain function, but it,
for some reason it became a switch to another life.
[inaudible]
number six. Am I dead?
Ooh, I hear some seagulls. You hear the seagulls? Yeah.
Where are they coming from? We just told the, I shut the, um,
the English Channel and the Atlantic.
So they've got you in a little box floating in the ocean.
We're not actually not that far away from, from the sea.
So we get lots of seagulls here. This is Barb rocks.
He's not really floating in a box in the ocean.
He's just in a box near the ocean.
And the reason we've connected our box in New York to his in England is because
of a question he was once asked.
If you work in the sort of line that I've worked in over the years,
you get the most bizarre statements and questions,
which is because Palsy neuropsychologist,
which means he diagnosis patients with various mental disorders.
And he describes this one case about eight years ago involving a woman named
Jeanie, just an ordinary pleasant middle aged woman from the north of England,
early fifties well loved by her family. She comes into his office,
he runs it through some basic tests.
I just did a basic assessment of as I would in that sort of case of general
intellectual level.
And at first she seemed pretty with it. She answered all his questions,
he seemed pretty alert. But then while she was,
she wasn't gonna have a conversation about whether [inaudible]
things seemed real. What does that mean? Well,
it's difficult to pin that one down.
She just felt that things weren't real.
She would point to objects in the room and say, well, that cup that doesn't,
it doesn't seem real, does it? Or the chair doesn't seem real.
It just doesn't feel real. So I can see it and I can describe it to you.
But it just doesn't feel real.
And the thing that really made me sit up was when she said,
um,
I forget the exact phrase, but it's in the book. Um, eventually Jeannie said,
am I dad and my dad? Yes. Do you think I'm dead? Do you think I,
I didn't respond immediately and I let the silence flow.
Jeanie smile, her face was lit with a benign perplexity.
There was a smear of toothpaste around the corner of her mouth.
She didn't seem to notice the droplets of tea spinning onto her dressing gun,
but there was a glint in her eye in the middle of the night. I was convinced,
she said, I thought they would come to take me away.
I can't say for sure that I'm dead. She continued.
The things are not the same. I don't feel real.
It seems to me I might be dead. How would I know if I was dead
and
immediately made me think? This may be an example of coats
syndrome. No one really knows what causes co-taught syndrome. It's very rare.
I mean I've, I've come across three cases,
but one of the symptoms he says is often this sense of deep sense that you're
somehow not completely here.
One idea about, um,
this syndrome is that somehow that that's a decoupling of thoughts and feelings,
which means what exactly he was, how to explain it to me.
The brain has two jobs. It's doing it all times.
The first is to keep track of what's happening outside your body.
Like the sites that are coming out.
You smell touch with your central experience of the world.
That most immediate consciousness of the body and the world and the body being
in the world.
All the while the brain also is maintaining this inner life where you think
thoughts and you have memories, personality,
what you normally think of when you think about yourself. You write,
what do you think happens in these, in this condition? Is it that outer?
Are you essential? Self somehow gets cut,
cut off from that inner mental you and it just drifts off to see leaving you
with just thoughts.
But it's the feelings that give us our in the moment sense of self.
So if you don't have feelings attached to faults and perception,
then you're like vapor. You're there,
but you have no weight isn't what you're describing.
Basically one version of the afterlife. Like my body's gone.
But some thing remains.
Yeah, I haven't thought of that. That's very,
very interesting way to think about it.
But is that any different than the story persisting in someone else's head?
[inaudible]
you guys know this group, that edge edge.org it's John Brock [inaudible] group.
Yeah, we do. That's David Eagleman again. And for number seven,
a brief excerpt from a conversation we had with him if I only had a brain. So,
so I just wrote an essay on there yesterday.
It came out to this big ideas that will change the world. That exactly. Yeah.
What's the thing that will change everything? And my answer was,
and I think this is something I'll actually see in my lifetime.
So the idea is silicone and mortality. In other words,
downloading your consciousness into a computer and will really have reached a
new point where there'll be a mortality.
Ah,
how would you figure this would work?
So imagine you make an exact copy of the three dimensional structure of the
brain, all the neurons, all the connections between the neurons,
the proteins inside the phosphorylation state to the proteins.
You make a copy of this whole thing.
What matters is the algorithms that are running on top of the brain,
it's not the wet gushy stuff that matters.
It's what that wet cushy stuff is implementing and the idea is that if you could
recreate the brain out of let's say beer cans and tennis balls and you get all
the structure the same and it runs the same algorithms, then that would be,
you would have your consciousness, your memories, your thoughts and so on. Yeah.
Right now it's science fiction because it's so much data.
Our current computers can handle it. Is that the only limitation? Just the, the,
the hard drive size where there are no,
there's other limitations with there too. There,
there are two limitations right now.
One is our imaging technology and the other is the amount of storage capacity
and error. I mean you get one Adam or two wrong,
and all of a sudden instead of your cat named Coco,
it's now named Boco and then you're not the same person. No, that's not true,
in fact, because every time you hit your head on a cabinet,
you're actually killing lots of neurons. But that doesn't change who you are.
You don't miss. Remember your cat's name. I mean,
imagine that you changed one word in, in the novel Moby Dick.
It would still be Moby Dick. Be Almost Moby Dick.
It would be almost Moby Dick. But,
but you are almost the same person day to day,
and you're never exactly the same person that you were yesterday because of the
small changes in your brain. But let's say, imagine that you're right,
despite Roberts objections, even imagining,
let's just say you think you're the Hubris.
What would you actually do with the Xerox brains to be immortal?
Don't you have new cotton than [inaudible]?
How would you interface with a xerox brain?
So the idea is if we can recreate a brain in zeros and ones on a computer,
then you could actually live inside of a virtual world
and you could enjoy living in this world indefinitely.
Or like the scarecrow
brain. He, he didn't have a real brain.
He had straw and a certificate. Well,
you don't actually know that you have a real brain either, right? One,
there are, there are modern philosophers who deal with this in a very,
in a real way, they ask how would we know if we are a simulation?
Why would we die if we were a simulation? He's not going to die. That's like,
ah, well so this, this is the point of my book.
Some is to illustrate that there are lots of possibilities out there, right?
Here it comes. Yeah. When you interrupt,
you are about to become immortal. So there,
there are many different stories written here and some of them,
God is actually a married couple that got separated and then reunited or that
God is the size of a micro
eight. Did we say eight or is it nine? I think it was nine. Yeah,
I think we're eight. Ineffable. Another story by David Eagleman and his book,
some red for us again by actor Jeffrey tambor.
When soldiers part ways at war's end,
the breakup of the platoon triggers the same emotion as the w. Well,
the death of a person, it's the final bloodless death of the war.
The same mood Hans actors on the drop of the final curtain after months of
working together,
something something greater than themselves is just died after a store closes
its doors on its final evening or a congress wraps its final session.
The participants amble away feeling that they were just part of something larger
than themselves, something they intuit had a life, even though they,
they can't quite put a finger on it in this way,
death is not only for humans, but for everything that exists.
And it turns out that anything that enjoys life enjoys an afterlife,
platoons in plays and stores in congresses, they don't end.
They just move on to a different dimension.
Although it's difficult for us to imagine how these beings interact.
They enjoy, uh, this delicious afterlife together.
They exchange stories of their adventures. They,
they laugh about good times and often. Well, just like us, just like humans,
they lament how short this thing is, how brief
it is.
It may seem mysterious to you that these organizations can live on without the
people who compose them, but the underlying principle, well, it's simple.
The afterlife is made of spirit. I mean, after all you,
you don't bring your kidney or your liver or your heart to the afterlife with
you. Instead, you gain independence from the pieces that make you up.
Now,
a consequence of this cosmic scheme is going to surprise you.
When you die.
You're aggrieved by all the atoms of which you were composed.
Yeah, I mean, they hung together for years,
whether in sheets of skin or communities as spleen, but with your death,
they don't die. Instead, they,
they part ways moving off in their separate directions.
Mourning the loss of a special time.
They shared together actually haunted by the feeling that everyone's playing
parts in something larger than themselves.
Something that had it's own life, something, um,
well, they can hardly put a finger on
[inaudible].
Alright. My name's Josh and I'm calling from Harlem, New York.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org thanks.
This is I'm jab boom.
Rod. I'm Robert Krulwich and today on the show, 14 meditations,
1211 1111 meditations on the moment of death.
And what happens after eight nine nine eight title,
which simply escapes me. Boo-Yah Mozart from producer Lulu Miller.
Hi there. Can you hear me?
Yes I can.
Okay, great. So I called it this guy at the University of Leicester.
Yeah. [inaudible] ceviche. I'm a,
I'm a ecologist who basically went from the history,
but in his spare time he's been studying what he calls
future fossils.
Like let's go ahead a hundred million years,
which is roughly at the time that separates us from the dinosaurs.
We will be dead. All the species that are around us will be dead.
So I asked him, well, any of our stuff, the books we write,
the buildings we make, well any of that still be here. And here's what he found.
Concrete is probably going to preserve pretty well. Glass will preserve,
but it will probably turn opaque bits of brickwork, carotid piping,
some types of plastic and our rubbish dumps all under Pritik of champs being
preserved. What about paper? Paper is again,
we can treat that paper is plant material.
It will carbonize just because when we see fossil plants,
they can be preserved for tens or even hundreds of millions of years.
So the shape of paper will be preserved almost forever.
Uh, but the print, the print on paper will almost certainly be lost.
If you have a, a book preserved, it will be like a little piece of,
of oblong coal.
So the idea is that we produce that I cannot see surviving us,
you know, so Shakespeare and Gerta and all the people we call the mortals,
you know, Mozart Music, um,
that information I think will be lost forever.
[inaudible]
oh one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
10 psi. Bertrand city, Sydney, it's a word of our own coinage,
cyber trinity and it comes to us from producer Emily Voight.
This story is about dealing with death in a world where no one really dies.
At the center of the story is a guy named Wyatt Amman.
I knew I at and uh, I consider him my best friend.
That's Donald Dover.
Wyatt and I both had office jobs at the same time and together we decided that
this wasn't enough because both of us are spending so much time in front of
computers.
So the goal was going to be to join the Peace Corps and we had talked about
doing the Peace Corps together,
but why it got things going. First he quits his job,
he signs up for the Peace Corps and within a few months was headed off to
Zambia.
He called me to see him off. And um,
we sat there and sat there and sat there sort of avoiding the fact that he was
going to actually have to leave. Um, finally he's like, all right,
you need to go home. I need to get on a plane. So, um,
he walked me to my car and, uh,
gave me a big hug and I said, yeah.
He said, uh, you've been a great friend to me.
[inaudible] I said, yeah, you too. And uh, he said,
don't worry, I'll be back in two years. Nobody's going to die.
But 10 weeks into the trip, why?
It was hanging out with some friends on the fourth floor of a hotel and he
leaned back against a window,
almost floor to ceiling and the play glass gave out.
He fell four stories and he bled to death. His lungs filled with blood.
He never regained consciousness
when the peace corps called it. I just said, I don't believe it. Who is this?
What are you, what kind of sick thing are you doing?
This is Jeannie m and why it's mom. He said, fatal injuries. I said,
what do you mean fatal? What does fatal mean?
[inaudible]
I couldn't, my mind would not comprehend what that word meant.
I th I felt so betrayed by God. Um,
I had prayed for Wyatt and had felt that God would keep him safe. And you know,
it isn't, it's, it's such a crock
[inaudible]
so two years go by
and right at the time that why it would have been returning from the peace
corps, something happened.
Jeanie, can you tell me about getting the letter?
Yeah, I remember.
So clearly Greg and I were both home and we went to the mailbox and walk to the
kitchen and um,
we ripped open the envelope and inside was a letter from Wyatt.
We were really unsure what was going on. It's hard to describe. It was,
um, it was really incredible.
So what happened is this before why it died,
he had been playing around on the Internet and he went to this site called
future me a website where you can send a letter to your future self.
Why he wrote his right before he joined the Peace Corps.
And the idea was that the site would hold onto it and email it back to him in
two years. But of course, why it wasn't there to get the letter.
But Donald, his friend found it and sent it.
And so Greg and I both stood there at the counter and we read the letter. Okay,
so what does it, what does it say dear future me, I'm leaving DC.
So far I've managed to do pretty much everything other than what I needed to do.
No, it's about the fact that he's leaving for Zambia. First of all,
I have no idea what to expect.
He talks about his ex-girlfriend sometimes love is like crack.
How he hates his office job.
I truly believe that I was meant to be a semi-transparent being, you know, he's,
he's sort of being a little, I want the Sistine Chapel,
not a ranch style home in the suburbs outlet or really captured who,
why it was my life is my canvas, you know,
with all his ramblings and these grandiose things already. Schizophrenia, Cli,
colorful, intricate in dizzyingly morphis.
He knows that he's seeing too much in that. He kind of has to humble himself.
How pretentious is that? And that's what he was like.
He was always keeping a check on himself. One thing's for sure.
I'm capable of rambling on and on and on and on and on and on and on.
I have the same problem. I just remember feeling,
I felt like, why had I just sent us a letter? Greg shook his head and he said,
that kid, you know, and um,
it was like a part of him was still alive.
[inaudible]
Emily [inaudible] let me just interrupt for just a second. Okay.
Because it will be easy to hear. The story is just like a fluke,
like a letter shows up from a kid who died and liquid.
It means to the mom and his friend. But no,
this might be where we're all headed, cause he internet, you know,
it's always on.
And one of the things that's happening is that there are sites that are popping
up that allow people to speak from beyond the grave and to keep on speaking.
In fact, David Eagleman, who we heard from earlier,
the guy who read those stories and a neuroscientist, he started one.
So I started the company, deathswitch.com this is a real thing.
There are hundreds of subscribers. Yeah, no kidding. Oh yeah.
The way it works is you sign up for the site and then you keep checking in with
the site to prove you're alive. And if you disappear for too long,
the computer deduces you are dead.
Then it sends out all those emails that you told it to see your company,
telling him what the passwords are to your family,
telling them where the gold is buried or even just to remind them that you love
them. And he says that these switches,
these desk switches are going off all the time.
But lots of people test the deaths, which is to make sure that it works.
So they might not be real yet, but they will be pretty soon.
So it's easy for him to imagine.
I'll let her to like this happy 87th birthday.
It's been 22 years since my death. I hope your life is proceeding delightfully,
which may sound funny, but imagine that that's you in the kitchen,
getting a letter from your mom or from someone that you lost too early.
How would you feel? Um,
it was like a part of him was still alive.
So after Jeannie gets the letter, what happens? Well,
Jeannie starts writing Wyatt as if he hadn't died.
What do you mean writing him where? Well, why?
It had been a huge blogger and Jeanie discovered that a lot of his blogs were
still active. One of them was even updating his age.
It shows his age is what he'd be now, you know,
it doesn't know that he's not here anymore.
So she goes on and leaves him comments.
My latest one was on November 5th of this year. Do you want me to read that one?
That'd be great. Why? It feels like you are still here living in
Zambia and it is 2005 I feel frantic to do something to stop the 17th from
happening in your mind when you comment on a blog. Oh Wyatt,
another holiday without you. Where do you picture that it's going well, I think,
I wish you could just let me know what it is like and how you feel now. Um,
I think I just figure it's like on a screen and somehow he's getting it.
Why it's dead
for Donald.
Getting the letter was just a reminder of that why had died and Zambia and in
fact the idea that technology could keep him around. I guess I'm sort of,
it just didn't work for Donald.
I sort of feel that the way I imagine why it felt in his letter he talks about,
um,
not being static and what to learn and grow and see how other wants to continue
moving and seeking and building and growing. And I will at rest,
it can be kind of frustrating. Like he's,
he's stuck in a 24 year old y. Um,
before I died we had, um, we decided we were Luddites.
They, we were anti-technology. And, um,
the hilarious part is that then wild then googled luddite to find out things
about Luddites. Um,
but initially the plan was to leave to meet why in Africa and when white died,
I knew that I still needed to make that break. So we did,
I left my office job to go live on a small island in the middle of Chesapeake
Bay to 240 Acre island. And I lived there with three other people.
There's no cell phone service. You won't be logging onto the Internet.
He sure why it would've left it there
and 11 goodbye.
Here's Peter Ward,
a paleontologist and professor of biology and earth and space sciences at the
University of Washington in 7 billion years.
Her son will suddenly go red giant
and the earth is just burned to a crisp. Is that happened
and like one morning or does that happen over several hundred years or actually
you take a few thousand years, but the oceans will have been actually long gone.
The oceans are going away in 2 billion years. Oh dear. Because the sun,
that nasty old sun just [inaudible] just keeps
getting brighter and brighter and brighter and about 50 to 60 centigrade,
we start
rapidly losing the ocean space.
This is the opposite of Noah's flood. Instead of [inaudible]
the gas descending into the giant oceans,
now the oceans pick up and go back into the sky. Exactly,
and then things get worse from there because 5 billion years after the oceans
are gone, the sun starts to expand
and it happens in
Hans.
There are actually four to five pulses that are going to take place.
The first four pulses will not eat up the earth,
but it will certainly stay around
six.
The whole surface will melt. It would be glowing.
Um,
the last one, the sun just keeps expanding.
Our Sun will expand be almost to the orbit of Mars.
So the earth is totally gone. I mean, it just gets snuffed out.
But the nice thing is that your Ropa will become the new Maui.
Yes, Jovian satellites.
If you buy real estate there now and now here is jerk sheet that will be the
tropics, Jovian Moon, Jovian Moon. How many are candidates for Maui's?
There's Europa and Ganymede and io, not so much,
but he's in Europa. When the ice melts on Europe as it was just an,
isn't it an all watery is just gonna be a nice warm ocean would just be a ball
of water ball of water. A hundred mile deep water too with that,
that's regular liquid water. H Two. Oh yes. Oh, it's beautiful stuff.
Taking the view. Think of the views of Jupiter under these. So spectacular.
The downside with these Jovian moons is that you couldn't breathe
when you left that out. Minor detail can breathe it fucking that.
You can certainly go water skiing. It's just have a little respirator on, oh,
that was a small little asterisk you've just gone to now.
It's just compared to the end of the world. That's minor detail. I see.
All right, so now let's go further out.
At what point does any possibility of solar system existence and ah,
that was tougher.
That was very tough because after the red giant we'd become a m mclass or a
dwarf,
which means the Sun after being this big now expanding Redstar made giant sinks
back into itself and becomes much, much, much smaller and much, much cooler.
So Europa, I live a little paradise now. Pleases exactly.
And then the only thing left is things like voyager, things that you, um,
you sent off that are still going off somewhere.
Bits of us, they're going and going and going and gone.
And the chance that they'll ever intersect a star is very small.
The end, the end.
Now, the final end, of course,
is way off into the future because the universe keeps expanding.
That means eventually Adams themselves is pulled apart.
Little Protons and neutrons.
They get ripped away from one another and we're somewhere else.
Something else somehow else.
Yeah, and then everything that is isn't
[inaudible]. Goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye.
Goodbye neutron.
You're playing Robert Krulwich by jet blue. Brad,
goodbye everyone.